وقد رصد مراسل الجزيره هشام زقوت تكدس
جثامين الشهداء في ساحه مستشفى شهداء
الاقصى في دير البلح بعد غارات اسرائيليه
مكثفه استهدفت وسط وجنوب قطاع
غزه كما ترى نحن هنا في مستشفى شهداء
الاقصى وربما الصوره تتحدث عن نفسها من
جراء هذا العدد الكبير من الشهداء لا سما
ان الشهداء ظلوا على الارض ملقون على
الارض بسبب عدم وجود اصلا متسع له لهؤلاء
الشهداء فما بالك ايضا بعشرات المصابين
جراء هذه الغارات العنيفه التي استهدفت
مخيما مكتظا بالسكان فيه عشرات من
النازحين عشرات من السكان وعندما تحدث
الغاره نحن نتحدث عن منازل تدمر عندما
تحدث الغاره فهناك دمار كبير لكن هناك
العشرات من الذين يتواجدون في المنازل هذا
اصيب فظل تحت الانقاض ينز وهذا استشهد
وهذا قسمه الركام الى نصفين وهذا فقد يده
وهذا فقد راسه من جراء هذه الغارات
العنيفه التي تستهدف هذه المنازل المدنيه
الفلسطينيه في بعد منتصف الليل ومنذ بدايه
هذه الحرب الاسرائيليه بعد منتصف الليل
تبدا الغارات تكون اكثر كثافه وبالتالي
الناس تكون في منازلها لجات الى هذه
المنازل تحاول ان تكون بامن وامان لكن رغم
كل ذلك يستهدفها الجيش الاسرائيلي
والطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه ومنذ بدايه
هذه الحرب ونحن نشهد هذه الغارات بعد
منتصف الليل والقنابل التي تسقطها هذه
الطائرات الاسرائيليه على هذه المنازل هي
قنابل لم نشهدها من قبل في اي حرب سابقه
بمعنى انها تدمر دمار كبير وتسقط عدد كبير
من الشهداء والدمار يكون في مربعات سكنيه
لم نشهد غاره واحده تدمر منزلا واحدا فقط
هي تدمر بعشرات المنازل المجاوره للمنزل
المستهدف ويكون هناك دمار كبير واعداد
كبيره من الشهداء هذه المره في مخيم
المغازي وهذه ليست المره الاولى التي يشهد
فيها مخيم المغازي مجزره بحجم هذه المجزره
هناك عده مجازر لكن مخيم المغازي من
المعروف انه مخيم مكتظ بالسكان مخيم فيه
المنازل متلاصقه مخيم ال يعني هو ازقه
عباره عن ازقه حتى لا تستطيع سيارات
الدفاع المدني وسيارات الاسعاف الدخول الى
قلب هذه المنازل من اجل انتشال الجثامين
واجلاء الجرحى وبالتالي هناك صعوبه اصلا
في عمليه الانتشال التي تتم اصلا بادوات
بسيطه وبادوات
بدائيه